[Music]
let me just say that it's spinning on
it's been a privilege it's been
something real we did something that no
one expected we fought back against all
of India and we fought bravely goddamn
it
well we all knew it was bound to come to
an end at some point
the sub gap is left less than 50,000 we
use all our cards we got nothing left
we got nothing and no one it look mosque
where are you where are you we lied
we're it's a Super Bowl I had mr. beast
Wall Street general furries are now
illegal in Germany oh well alright then
when many balance is out then it's okay
good evening I'm Gloria Borger I'm not
supposed to have my opinion but finally
they put the furries in jail that is
excellent thumbs of Floria
all right welcome to pew news we have a
lot of stories to cover a lot of up sees
to go through number one
oopsie number one rebels pity pie didn't
you see the BBC did a story on the whole
PD pie hacking and well first of all
absolutely beautiful vector art well is
that nose and beard Thank You BBC very
cool and they asked the question here in
the title could hacking printers ruin
your life and I'm gonna go ahead and say
no no we didn't at least in this case
you probably heard about the printer
hack already where a couple hackers
hacked uh printers to print that the
posts are saying subscribe to PewDiePie
you know it was a combination of a good
mean for a funny cost but also doing
something positive in his sense of it's
a hack that spreads awareness that
people's printers are actually
unprotected and that's probably
something you should fix I mean I heard
even police stations printed them so
it's pretty concerning and it's raising
awareness for that but BBC kind of
showed more than the dark side of this
whole hack for hacks one YouTube star
someone hacked printers overnight same
Global News then they vanished whoa they
went incognito then they bench
FBI's like where did they go beautiful
the Swedish comedians army of followers
got to work a bizarre campaign was
launched including billboards leafleting
and posters one fan calling himself
hacker giraffe decided to take it to an
extreme even criminal level he hacked an
estimated 50,000 printers forcing them
to produce a poster in support of to
depart those poor printers without
consent printed this black and white
image I can't believe it this criminal
level if anything these kids should get
hired for doing something
groundbreaking so we're that they go in
this illegal level like yeah technically
you're not allowed to do that I'm sure I
don't know honestly I don't honestly
don't even know I was involved in the
peopie in the things catch I'm gonna
tell you how we did it whatever thought
you anonymously talked about it like
they broke into a bank and stole our
often user it was the exposure they've
been dreaming of but then everything
changed I think sarcastic because they
make it look like it's a murder
yeah exactly the tone of this is no
strain this number here was about
seventy sixty thousand and now it's
dropped down to thirty nine thousand so
I believe through our attempts for
positive difference and these people
were secretly pretty well there you go
there you go there's no doubt that fun
and fame was a big part of the
motivation here for these teen hackers
have made an impact in an area where
security is an increasing concern we
don't know whether or not the
authorities are trying to find them
there's a good chance that we're looking
over their shoulders the authorities
that correct the idea that they have to
look over their shoulder in case they
would ever get arrested for the printer
Hank I don't know man it doesn't really
seem that accurate but that's just my
opinion which I'm not supposed to have
next news James Charles everyone's
favorite youtuber
visited the UK and it was absolute
madness apparently there were so many
people that came to James Charles I
think it's his new makeup palette I'm
not sure or meet-and-greet thing that
the whole mall just shut down I mean
that's crazy I mean the whole mall just
got completely overrun apparently
brought traffic so that people couldn't
come home from work afterwards and it
was his overall madness but a lot of
people directed that annoyance which is
understandable that if you can't get
home or whatever they directed that to
James Charles obviously which is also a
kind of a dumb ass way to look at things
because clearly this is not his fault or
at least maybe not directly so let's
look at some reactions from the news
about this whole event what kind of
common is that what the hell man that's
because I take advice from a woman from
a wham boys can't do makeup you silly
little boys a lot of the smug faces she
made they make as well like an article
by mail online it came out about this as
well and said who tube ha ha ha
virtually unknown us bloggers virtually
unknown and his eight thousand screaming
fans to bring Birmingham city centre to
a shocked standstill with extra police
drafted amid fresh beers as he opens
cosmetics store
oh you opens the cosmetics are ok James
Charles responded with virtually unknown
an eight thousand screaming fans should
not be used in the same sense I I
noticed that they they changed his
headlight as well it now says that I
don't know you was make a blogger and
it's a fastened great there you go so
they realize at least also really life
is radio reporting um but his chunk no I
think he gets 10 million viewers that's
very different to hate yep so what's
going on oh three four five six oh six
oh nine seven three what what does this
say about Fame in the modern because
newspaper job is usually done by
journalists I cover Fame why are why
don't I know about James Charles given I
read every newspaper every day Oh three
four five six oh six like how we
answered his own question why do I know
by this youtuber cuz I read the news
because I feel very sorry for West
Midlands Police how the hell could they
have been known oh why am i uneducated
on this matter I read the news every day
do you watch pew news because then we
wouldn't have this problem I don't know
it's funny to me cuz I don't know that
much about James Charles to be honest
but he never struck me as like that
content well maybe is actually yeah it's
more like I expect this kind of
treatment for for PewDiePie with the the
kind of snarky sarcasm and and there ooh
who is this guy or whatever but the fact
that other youtubers get also get the
same treatment it's kind of it's almost
sad in a way it's always so spiteful and
with the tone of jealousy whenever
there's reporting of new media coming
from old media essentially this failure
to understand it just makes them look so
pity and
without realizing it themselves honestly
so next news the Shorty Awards yay the
Shorty Awards the most respected award
show of all time
hey I won I mean Peter Pius won a shorty
award it broke in the mail I'm sorry
sure - you're worse
maybe you shouldn't send a piece of
glass in the mail that's just my opinion
people were mad at how badly the
nominations were for example the mean
parody account the most important
category of all time I mean where's
doling dark where's grande huh you tell
me why is the same picture of Chris
Pratt nominated ok this [ __ ] tired this
doled get it out of my sight am I
supposed to have my opinion there's
garbage I know none of these memes sirs
really the only reason I bring up this
story is because I don't mean to break
people's bubble here essentially all
award shows they're garbage
ok they're bogus it's just a play that I
brought place into it's a sure odd that
everyone plays into it I guess you could
say you know you really wanted to be
something that actually commemorates and
congratulate the people that did wet
well a certain year but that's rarely
the case it's more about who's there to
accept the award it's more about how can
they bring as much attention to their
award show as possible with these fake
voting's or whatever that doesn't really
make a difference and it's all kind of
bull of politics and corporate chilling
don't believe me the Black Panther Black
Panther was an Oscar nominee for what
category you might ask maybe best
soundtrack nope
Best Picture Best Picture Black Panther
everyone of course of course it is I
like this story as well Bret Easton
Ellis questions Black Panther Oscar
nomination for Best Picture
does it really deserve one that's news
they might as well put Bret Easton Ellis
saves what's on everyone's mind how dare
you question the Black Panther being
Oscar nominated for Best Picture I'm
coaching
listen I would love for award shows to
be what they actually appear to be I'm
just saying they're not okay and if you
level 10,000 woke like I am then maybe
you would realize
oopsie number something next news we're
going fast and we're going hard today
boys
ariana grande got a tattoo this is my
favorite story this month ariana grande
mocked for Japanese typo basically
ariana grande got a tattoo she posted it
on her Instagram or Twitter or whatever
no one cares a hand tattoo first of all
great idea Ariana Grande
hand tattoos are always a great idea so
basically what the Japanese symbols are
saying is Japanese barbecue grill so
finally she missed out on a couple of
characters so I don't know what it was
supposed to mean but she ended up with
Japanese barbecue grill everyone and I
thought that's a nice that's a nice
tattoo to have with my extra-large
grilling machine with temperature
control makes prepare and delicious food
quick and easy it's yours for just 99 98
plus shipping and handling
call 1-866-931-6190 now have to add in a
couple extra letters to a to fit to make
sure you meant what it meant so now she
just have it on her palm
great job please if you ever get a
tattoo
make sure you double-check it okay it's
always good to double check things that
will last forever
just a small little hint that maybe
wasn't obvious apparently next notes
okay
okay these things are hilarious I love
this so much
okay she pleads guilty to 90 criminal
counts detailed in immersion so as you
guys we reported recently on Pew News
Nikesh d69 was arrested for racketeering
and it looked pretty bad four six nine
it looks like it was gonna face a long
time in prison and now we have an actual
estimate of what that number is going to
be since he pled guilty he could face up
to forty seven years of oppression now
why is this number so important when he
is 22 he's been sentenced to 47 years in
prison Takeshi 69 will get out of jail
when he is six nine if this is not an
example of a self-fulfilling prophecy I
don't know what is god bless you Takeshi
next news YouTube star Austen jokes
please guilty to producing child porn
this was a story back in 2015 where this
youtuber admitted to asking fans to
twerk on camera for them mind you this
is underage fans as well your opinion
based off of the full story and the
truth this guy looks like such a smug
little hole just in in the mixed cell
and the things he standard nice response
video just working the dance move it's
not something that I'm proud of it's not
something that I think is right and I
shouldn't have done it
Austin basically says it was just
twerking videos and and that was it now
the full story comes out and he pleads
guilty to half a dozen videos and then
he tried to get others should do the
same the federal complaint details
videos and conversations with two
fourteen-year-old girls including at one
point Jones trying to get the girl to
take her clothes off by telling her to
prove she is his biggest fan she doesn't
have to cry someone else he had two
girls on camera 14 year old telling them
to dress take their clothes up to prove
that there
his biggest fan like that's just
straight-up disgusting manipulative
that makes me ashamed to be a youtuber I
guess this guy will be twerking in
prison for now on lot of oopsies go went
on guys I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but goddamn I love it now lastly
this is not an oopsie I don't know how
to talk about this I don't know what to
say
but Eugenia Cooney uploaded this video a
few days ago and I just really wanted
people to send her as much support and
love as possible and I mean I really
mean that I think that's the only thing
she needs right now and I hope that she
will listen to people and try and
understand where they're coming from and
actually hopefully get some help because
she honestly seems like I love the girl
and this is just Ariane to look at
that's it for puny hope you guys enjoyed
this episode remember to give lots of
love and kisses to the like button
subscribe if you haven't oh my god
please subscribe ups we have to make it
a Superbowl at least come on guys the
season finale we can't quit now I'm
poppy Harlow and it's what gave link
Able's oh my
[Music]